oh my God look at your so I'm gonna be
putting prosthetic acne on my face we're
gonna wear it for a day today right both
my parents have really clear skin and
that was just passed on to me I can't
take credit for any of that I definitely
had acne for most of my teen years I'm
really nervous it up as office today I'm
ready to be educated my name is dr. Alex
Martin for the past 30 years I have seen
various degrees hormonal II related acne
is this making puberty if you're giving
me this acne is it stache mm-hmm every
13 year old boy's mortal enemy ranging
from very minor outbreaks to the most
severe cystic acne so you're about to
see yourself yeah okay so I'm gonna take
a look oh whoa oh dude I have plans
today I'm just like looking at myself
and wondering what people are gonna say
I posted a selfie on Instagram all the
comments were just people like trying to
console' me uh well my friends are
mostly [ __ ] so okay when I posted the
picture was a lot of guys who I think
have found me attractive at some point
of my life we're about the need that it
was the right time to to tell me how
terrible I look social anxiety seems to
be a result of dealing with acne finding
it very hard to like look people right
in the face I'm kind of amazed at how
many people took no issue with just
staring at me when people stared it felt
like indeed you have zits
the first interaction we have with
people is by looking at them so people
fall guilty of staring I think what we
learned here is to have more empathy you
cannot really replicate exactly the
experience of the occupation really
bummed out right now can only imagine
how it feels to wake up to an acne
breakout and have to get through the day
but psychologically I think you're
gaining a lot of information I'm kind of
frustrated with myself because of how I
very badly want to tell them that it's
fake so my day is kind of turned around
get us didn't really give a [ __ ] at the
end of the day but that was not brought
on by just myself it was brought on by
my friend
I didn't want to cause I made her come
out because she's nothing to be ashamed
and the beginning I was kind of
emotional and sad and I realized I'm
hungry I wanna hang out with my friends
I want to laugh I have never been so
excited to finish with shooting a video
I felt super duper self-conscious of the
way I look is anybody who is dealing
with hackneyed you are so much stronger
than me I had acne for a day and I
wanted to hide under a rock I'm sure
it's very genetic I'm sure you can go to
the dermatologist and it takes time I
think it's just important to just
practice self-love in other ways it's
really character and the talent that
counts not superficial beauty this
experiment not only it made me
appreciate and understand the
insecurities of acne but made me just
like love myself a little bit more this
whole thing has been very helpful with
that if I was a stranger and I asked for
your number would you what would you say
I'll give you half on my number let me
see what your personality like and then
IQ the other hand I get three and a half
digits that's what this basically